hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carol you may
have heard there is a crisis in physics
no there's not I mean there's little
tiny crisis but that's the very standard
procedure if you're doing science at The
Cutting Edge there all sorts of puzzles
that we don't know the answer to I did a
long solo podcast about it last year
don't uh worry about it you can check
everything out there but look you have
to be honest there is something weird
about the present state of particle
physics of fundamental physics as we
talk about it the crisis in physics talk
is not at all about you know
astrophysics or condensed matter physics
or Atomic physics it's really about the
standard model of particle physics our
best current theory of the fundamental
laws of nature and the elementary
interactions between fields and
particles and that's because the
standard model has this strange status
as a theory that fits all the data as
far as We Know there's again little
anomalies here and there that we could
talk about but for the most part for
decades now the standard model has just
fit all the data but it's certainly not
the final answer it's definitely not the
final Theory of Everything for obvious
reasons as well as for subtle reasons
the obvious reasons include that it
doesn't include gravity doesn't include
dark matter doesn't explain the Big Bang
the difference between matter and
antimatter in the universe and so on but
also the more subtle reasons are things
like it looks ugly it's both ugly and
beautiful you you really have to dig
into the standard model to appreciate
what's going on it's ungainly let's put
it that way there's a lot of moving
Parts the weak interactions treat
left-handed particles and right-handed
particles differently the strong
interactions don't there's different
Generations that seem just like copies
of each other but they're a little bit
different the different particles have
different masses which basically seem
pull out of a hat we don't know why all
these masses are what they are and so on
and so on it does not look like the
level of austere compellingness that you
would expect a final Theory to have and
that feature of the standard model the
fact that it is kind of bizarre kind of
weird kind of ungainly is reflected in
how it came to be that's what we're
talking about today we have Chris quig
who is a particle physicist theorist at
fery lab and who has written a book with
Robert Khan as his co-author called
Grace in all Simplicity Beauty truth and
wonders on the path to the higs boson
and new laws of nature so basically the
idea is that Chris quig and Bob gon who
are both very good writers and who lived
through much of this history have
written a book that tells the history of
how modern particle physics developed
the standard model in particular
particular up to the higs BOS on like
the subtitle says with an emphasis on
all of the twists and turns along the
way and the human beings who made it
happen so it's not like the book that
I'm just trying to finish right now um a
bunch of equations about gauge Theory
and symmetry breaking and things like
that it's a bunch of stories about
people and how they lived and the
decisions that they were making because
while you're doing science while you're
in the middle of it you don't know
whether a certain approach is going to
work or not work etc sometimes as as
Chris will say in the podcast you get
the right answer and you don't even know
it yourself you don't even trust your
own equations going back to Paul dur not
quite trusting the prediction he made
for antimatter in the dur equation so I
think that this discussion that we're
going to have here illuminates a lot of
how the standard model came to be which
is just a giant bizarre Byzantine story
you know you can tell the story of the
origin of general relativity and it's
mostly Albert Einstein you know he had
help he was talking to people but it's
mostly that one guy even the origin of
quantum mechanics it's it becomes pretty
clear there were a couple of different
strands you know that led to Heisenberg
and Schrodinger and then Bor and
Einstein and their friends had to Duke
out how to interpret it all but it does
you know fit into a relatively compact
container whereas the standard model is
just so many names so many particles so
many ideas and Concepts that had to be
invented despite the fact that we get
into the weeds a little bit and what
some of those concepts are we don't get
nearly as into the weeds as we could
have let's put it that way but I hope
that not only will this conversation
convey some of the interest and
excitement of the standard model but
also help people understand the mindset
of physicists as these things are going
on you have some new experimental
Discovery it doesn't fit in or you have
some new theoretical idea it looks too
good to be true how can you apply it
right you're going to guess right
sometimes you're going to guess wrong
sometimes that's the story of our lives
and it's led us to a pretty good place
in modern fundamental physics so let's
[Music]
go Chris quig welcome to the mindscape
podcast thank you Sean it's pleasure to
be with you so you've written this uh
wonderful book now it's about particle
physics modern physics Etc and that's
what you do for a living but it's a
different kind of book that I'm used to
reading about that subject matter you
know we both come across many such books
but you've taken two things number one a
kind of historical angle you go into
much more detail than average about the
personalities the the the events that
happened but despite the fact number two
that you have a historical angle it's
it's not in chronological order you you
you hop back and forth a lot which maybe
is more like how real physicists think
about their background and their history
but but before we get into the physics
tell me a little bit about the book like
what made you write it this way with
your collaborator Robert Khan uh yes so
you've you've hit a an important point
for us and that is that the way science
progresses the way we physicists think
is hopping around here and there there
are many things that we hear for the
first time
and that don't make an impression on us
the way they should have and there are
also many um experimental technological
innovations as well as theoretical ideas
that when first proposed are applied to
what turns out to be the wrong problem
we'll see that coming up luckily luckily
we have memories at least some of us in
our community we have libraries and so
these uh these ideas or techniques can
later find good application so that was
part of it that we wanted to uh get away
from the strict logical progression yeah
uh because even in our own work we
haven't known things to go that way and
certainly in the grand sweep of science
that's not the way it goes um we wanted
to pay um attention to and show our
respect for the people who do science
now and in the past not just the ones
who have the fancy ideas
or are lucky enough to make the the
great experimental or observational
breakthroughs but uh people who
contribute to the technology and to the
techniques that allow us to to push
forward so that was the idea it's a love
letter in a way to many of those people
and our other guiding principle was that
we were writing for people we would like
to have a conversation with now as you
know in your podcast in a in a book
convers ation seems kind of one-sided
because only one person is is emitting
at a time nevertheless the way we think
about it I'm sure this is true for you
in your classes even is that you imagine
people should be talking back to you
altering their opinions maybe objecting
to what you say and so on and so um
that's what we set out to do it's
wonderful yeah and so the I'll I'm going
to disappoint you right from the start
because your book is too long for us to
cover everything interesting in the in
the scope of this podcast so I I was
thinking really hard about where to
start and I think that maybe Emmy nther
is a good place to start because
symmetry plays such an important role in
your book and you have some great
stories or at least some great color
about her life that I wasn't aware of so
talk a little about Emy nerder and you
know what is the role that she plays to
the modern physicist very good uh let me
start with the way we introduced that
chapter uh which also
represents one of the ideas that we had
in writing the book um not to give pH
physics lectures not to have an
examination at the end of every chapter
of course but to engage people in topics
that they've already perhaps heard about
or thought about and then use those as
ways of getting into the physics or
mathematical content that we we want to
start and talk about so we actually
begin that that chapter that introduces
Emmy with um a little disc discursion on
um uh Lou Sullivan the famous Chicago
architect that you will remember from
your time here uh who in annunciated the
principle that form follows function he
was rebelling against the neoclassical
tradition in which every building had to
look like a Roman Temple yeah and argued
uh chiefly in in uh in the context of of
department stores
and uh warehouses and things like that
that the building should actually looked
like what it does and you should be able
to tell what it's going to do so he he
had a a slogan which is summarized in
architectural School design school and
such uh form follows
function and you will know and our
readers will now know that we physicists
have for about the past 50 years under
understood that it's a good idea to turn
that slogan on its head and to say the
function follows form which is a sort of
pithy way of saying that the fundamental
interactions of nature the forces that
we talk about follow from symmetries
from the form of things so that
originated that idea originated in its
general form in work that a German
physicist German mathematician named Emy
nter did in 198 18 she a very
interesting character um she was the
child of a mathematician her brothers
were mathematicians but she was a
girl which meant that there were certain
obstacles to her pursuing education in a
career her original U studies were in
the a a fancy School in erlong where she
grew up in Germany
for promising young women of an
aspirational group uh and she was
certified to teach foreign languages
namely English and
French however uh because of her
background and her native ability she
was taking instruction on the side in
mathematics she applied to u to the
university in erong where her father was
a member of the math department and it
was not possible for a young woman that
would be too disturbing for a young
woman to enter the university so she
couldn't do that she applied for
permission to audit courses and that was
given on the basis of this private
tuition that she'd taken from
mathematicians never and so she was was
able to listen in uh one year later
after she her failed entry into airong
she was admitted admitted to the great
University of gingan where every great
German mathematician that we've ever
heard of either passed through or was in
Residence and I think her first semester
there she heard um I guess gaus was dead
but she heard lectures from corant and
Hilbert and kleene and uh schwar Shield
people like this so I I've said to my
students when recounting this to them
that if that's your first first
semester e either you're history or
you're hooked so luckily for us sem
notor was was hooked
the authorities relented a little bit
she was able to enter ER Logan as a
graduate student and took her PhD there
from
uh an interesting man named pal Gordan
physicists know this person from his
work with another man named Alfred kpch
oh no I hate these people there actually
were people who gave us these famous
coefficients that we worked on and she
wrote a thesis for him that was heavy on
computation and which she described
after the fact by the colorful German
word Mist
Mis which means in a polite translation
D and which which I first encountered in
high school when I was reading fa
because one of F's Mis F's Misadventures
is to end up with his head stuck in a
pile of D yeah okay good so that
resonated with me anyway so she in 1918
she wrote this uh wonderful paper she
had been engaged by Klein and Hilbert to
help them out they were puzzled about uh
some aspects of the general theory of
relativity which was new at that time
and in particular you having written a
textbook on the subject will know very
well that energy conservation this
fundamental law that we uh we use
everywhere doesn't look the same in
general relativity as it does in the
rest of physics it looks sort of like an
identity or something rather than a yeah
constraint
and Klein and Hilbert were puzzled about
this so they brought her back back to uh
um
gutan and she chatted with them and did
things on the side then she wrote this
famous paper in which there are two
theorems and the theorems have to do
with the connection between symmetries a
sameness before and after you make some
operation you know think of a a drop of
water in the absence of gravity it's
perfectly spherical you could look at it
from every any direction it's the same
um and what she found in the first
theorem is that every such symmetry is
related to a conservation law so turning
things around is relation related to the
conservation of angular momentum famous
thing given by the uh ice skater
analogy uh independence of time is
related to the conservation of energy
and Independence of place the
conservation of momentum
this is a fantastic breakthrough in a
sense because until this time people
were still fooling around trying to
understand what were the quantities that
were useful to talk talk about as
conserved and the conservation laws were
empirical regularities exactly yeah now
you know that they come from somewhere
and so if you give up energy
conservation it must mean that the laws
of nature are changing in time in a
predictable or unpredictable way and so
on so that that by itself is a great
Insight now pieces of this were known
before uh so I think it didn't make too
much of a splash because physicists said
oh yeah I could have worked out that
particular example I should have known
this and so on so it it didn't get
people jumping up and down the second
theorem is uh even more powerful and it
is the basis of the way we think about
the fundamental interactions today and
that is that if you allow these symmetry
operations these
changes to depend on the time or the
location at which they're
done you can also make theories of that
kind but in order for that to work there
has to be some
communication of what's happened what
you've done it one place to another
place so it knows how to catch up and do
things and that it turns out when
properly understood is the basis for the
fundamental interactions because you
need a messenger to go from here here to
there at about the same time uh Herman v
a famous math mathematical physicist and
one of the people most
responsible long before we were born for
introducing symmetry Concepts into
fundamental physics had his own idea
that he could make a unified theory of
all the fundamental interactions some
things never change there there were two
fundamental interactions at the time
gravitation and
electromagnetism and he had this scheme
that we now think of as kakami in which
the the size of a measuring rule would
change the intervals would change from
position to position and that would give
you electromagnetism and gravity it
doesn't uh poor Herman was uh trying to
do this before quantum mechanics had
been invented so he was working at a
certain disadvantage there's a lot of
back and forth Einstein himself pointed
out svile that if that were the the case
then the outcome would be dependent on
the path you took to go from here to
there and that sounds like a no no then
quantum mechanics came and other people
uh helped him out and by the end of the
20s he understood that you could do an
utter like transformation but of a very
weird kind in which the thing that
you're changing is not the measuring
stick or the direction but the quantum
mechanical phase the phase of the
quantum mechanical wave function and
that leads you to electromagnetism it
makes makes it uh obligatory to have a
photon a carrier of electromagnetism and
so on uh okay so that was great progress
and you know I'll just I'll just
interrupt just for a second to say uh
it's all you know you're you're kind of
breaking my heart here because I just
finished copy editing my next book which
is uh called Quant and Fields it's a
popular level book about quantum
mechanics and field Theory but it shows
people all the equations so I talk about
what a connection is what gauge
Transformations are and but it's very
short I I was very I'm not allowed to
ramble on for too long and so like this
historical background of vile and nther
and and I I wasn't able to talk about
any of that stuff but it is fascinating
yeah I I want to say that I'm looking
forward to that book because I the when
I back in my days as a
professor I was given the gift of
teaching grad graduate quantum mechanics
which you will know is a fantastic
course and it opens the world to to your
students back in those days it was
before Quantum information was a topic
in such courses so I'm looking forward
to learning what I didn't teach in those
days I will I will let you know Chris
that my graduate Quantum class was not a
wonderful experience actually it's not
all that's not uniform that's not a
symmetry well I didn't say that mine was
for my students but it was really great
for me anyway okay so you know here's
this F what we now recognize as a
fantastic tool nobody jumped up and down
about it nobody applied it in different
ways and I think there are two reasons
from that and it you know professional
historians perhaps have gone into this
or if they haven't they should here's
gutan gutan is one of the places quantum
mechanics is being invented yeah and it
is this Temple of mathematics anybody
who ever was anyone after Plato or
somebody
Archimedes uh was in in gingan at a time
going back to gaus who is the if you
look at our our scientific Heritage all
of us are descended from gaus because he
was the only one at the time so they
didn't do anything with it now why could
that be I think it there was a lot of
interplay between the physicists and the
mathematicians corant and Hilbert wrote
their famous book on methods of
mathematical physics which is one of the
few places where you actually find a
mention of notor theory
it's about two
paragraphs um and I think the reason for
this other than there was stuff to do
that was that there was no other
symmetry to apply it to right it was
another decade before isospin the
similarity between protons and neutrons
was recognized because after all you
needed a neutron to be discovered before
you could posit a
symmetry um there's so a wonderful
report from verer Heisenberg who was one
of the inventors of iser spin conceived
the notion and he confesses that he
never read Nutters paper yeah and I
think again it goes back to when you
hear the first applications of it you
nod your head and say oh yeah and then
so and I have to say a couple of the
Gods of our the generation just above
ours have told me they never met read
the paper either you know it was part of
the air but it was part of the air in a
rather uh distilled form so the
application of this in the way that we
think of as modern came in the
1950s when Cen yangang and Bob
Mills took had the idea that instead of
just using isospin symmetry this
similarity or sameness between protons
and neutrons if you ignore electric
charge um as a way of doing
classifications of nuclear levels and
stuff to say that that could be a
Precision dependent
uh symmetry that you impose the way Yang
put it I had the The Good Fortune to
learn it from his lips was um almost a
statement of democracy that if I get to
choose the convention for what's a
proton and neutron shouldn't you get to
choose your own shouldn't everybody in
every seat in the auditorium get to CH
so they worked that out and they found
following notter second theorem that it
gives rise to a theory of interactions
among protons and neutrons so people
were looking for that a theory of
nuclear forces it had the little
shortcoming that it didn't have any pons
in it which we now know or the dominant
Force dominant source of the nuclear
force and the force it did have was U
Photon likee so zero mass for the force
carriers infinite range which wouldn't
explain the fact that the nuclei are all
teeny tiny right or at least tiny short
range forces yeah so it was it's one of
these examples that we encounter
frequently of a brilliant penetrating
Insight applied to the wrong problem I
want to dig of course much more into
that but but I just want to take
advantage of having you here having just
written this book to fill in a couple of
the personal details with nerder because
number one I get this weird impression
that obviously there's a lot of
discrimination against women uh at the
time but the very top people that your
David hilberts and your Albert
Einstein's absolutely appreciated her it
was sort of the background bureaucracy
that made her life very hard yes so she
had three strikes against her she was a
woman she was a Jew from a Jewish Family
and she was a pacifist not only a
pacifist but one whose uh best friends
other than the ones in Gigan were in
Russia and this made her an object of
deep suspicion for the Nazi
characters um even before that she was
she was a subject of discrimination for
all of those things she had a brief
flowering of her career in good again
when um after the first world war the U
the vimar Republic came in and had lots
of reforms wokeness people would call it
today and removed many of the barriers
so she began to have a more regular
career Hilbert and kleene had before
that announced courses that they would
give assisted by Foy
nerder the principal would show up for
the first class this may be a tradition
some
universities and and U say hello
students here Here I Am the great man uh
tomorrow you'll hear from FR I not her
and she would give these courses uh so
she was probably paid under the table or
something from that after the reform she
became a privat doent and could be paid
directly by students and in gutan with
all these Gods around she of course was
younger than many of the Gods and
probably a little friskier uh she
attracted a codery of really devoted
students many of whom wrote textbooks
that at least I I read in my my youth
and maybe you did too um and there are
great stories of them following her her
she love loved to walk and talk at the
same time and there are great stories of
of uh Emmy leading her Nutter Boys
around
erong um in a Rowdy Bunch yeah according
to the locals and they'd go around and
around and she's always talking about
mathematics
um she gave a lot of lectures one of her
peers was a man named Amil Artin who
also was a famous lecturer I think he
ended up at Notre Dame um later on and I
read one of his his dist distillations
of of their work the two of them were
inventing modern AR algebra together
with the their students and others and
the transcription and
translation of the
lectures so that ordinary mathematicians
if not ordinary people could understand
that was done by some of these followers
um I really I really liked that uh
anecdote in your book because it it
fills in some of what it must have been
like because you hear about ner you
obviously great mathematician made
amazing contributions and suffered
discrimination Etc but there was Joy
there too right it wasn't all like
discrimination and annoyance like there
was there was there was like you said
friskiness and rambunctiousness which is
great yeah um I mean there other stories
of uh uh people enduring a long seminar
walking home through the rain
and Emmy just wants to stop on every
street corner and talk about the lecture
and they just want to get in out of the
rain so uh if if we could only all have
exactly that much enthusiasm exactly
what could we do okay so we just have to
pass over lots of good things because
there's too much history here but but
let's skip to the 1950s where you've
already sort of led us to with with Yang
and Mills I mean so nerder and vile have
this idea that symmetry somehow really
important right not just
leading to conserved quantities but even
maybe leading to forces of nature what
was in the 50s like what would people
have said professional physicist if you
said what are the forces of nature like
Quantum field Theory had been more or
less established then right yes so
Quantum electr Dynamics had been
invented and perfected to the uh to the
taste of almost everyone except draak
who objected to the way we make
calculations uh felt that there must be
a better way which all of us would not
object to if we could only find it um so
that by that time the nuclear force
binding protons and neutrons together
into uh nuclei had been established and
the weak interaction was identified this
is the one first responsible for radio
Radioactive beta Decay so the emission
of an electron by a radioactive
substance uh for a brief moment it was
imagined that those two were the same MH
but they're not mhm as experiment showed
um and the theory of the weak
interaction ba of Decay interaction was
invented in the 19 1930s by enrio
fmy cloning and
generalizing what Paul dur had done for
Quantum electrodynamics and it had a
very important idea in it and that is
that the electron that's emitted by a
radioactive nucleus wasn't there to
begin with so it wasn't living inside
the nucleus but that it was created at
the instant of Decay kind of spooky but
not as spooky as what you'd have have to
say if it were living inside all the
time as became clear when the first
positron decays Edie electron decays
were seen because that would be really
weird for Edy matter to be living inside
the the
nucleus
um fmy invented this uh as a I say fmy
had written
a a scan on dra's theory of quantum
electrodynamics which even in my days in
graduate school we are advised to to
read a famous paper in reviews of modern
physics so it's before Richard Fineman
and uh others but quite brilliant in its
in its uh conceptualization of things so
he generalized that for the weak
interactions and to a large
extent at least until the time I was
born that was the theory of the weak
interactions can I ask just a slightly
technical question but these days we we
we do and we will in the rest of this
podcast talk about Quantum field Theory
right electrons and neut neutrinos and
positrons are all vibrations in Quantum
Fields my impression is that that wasn't
the way you would have talked in the
1920s like that electrons were particles
the electromagnetic field was a field
and I I tend to give fairy a little bit
of credit for starting to think of the
matter particles as fields and really
doing field theory is that is that right
or am I just
projecting uh well he was a heck of a
guy so i' give him credit for lots of
things I think that actually began with
dur yeah okay 1928 to
1932 um and we tell stories about dur in
the in the book I had the opportunity to
meet dur a couple of times and one of
the stories we tell
is there was a
time I thought he was quite ancient in
fact I thought he was so ancient that he
must have been uh reconstituted for for
the
event and I think he was younger than I
am now uh so you know it's the third or
fourth time I had met him I gave a
colloquium on quantum mechanics and the
great man was sitting in the front row
smiling cryptically from time to time so
I I took that as a good sign whether as
a good sign or not and there's a
cocktail party afterwards so which I
finally got up my my courage and said
Professor D dur I've been wondering
about this thing that puzzles me when he
made his theory and there had to be a
counterpart to the electron that had
positive
charge he tried to interpret that as the
proton which if you trust his equations
was
nuts as I think he
knew and it turns out to be the
anti-electron the positron and so it's
very mysterious why this man who trusted
Beauty and Mathematics and rigor so much
and um he he was a marvelous character
so he always would have a pregnant pause
before he
answered and in this case he took longer
than
usual and I could see his eyebrows
wrinkling in an interesting way he put
his his chin down on his chest the way
he usually did but he kept it there for
a long time and during that time he
allowed me to estimate just how long a
line of young fools I had just joined by
asking this question and then he said he
he actually confessed sort of he said at
that time it just
wasn't respectable to propose new
particles now he was partly criticizing
people who were of my generation who
were introducing new particles every day
but it was and then he he elaborated a
little bit I think he looked back on it
as a slight failure of nerve yeah uh
which we from the outside might have
guessed uh except that he was a really
clever guy so we expect him to be uh
immune to such things anyway so that
that was an opportunity to uh to hear at
least some version of the story from
one of the creators well I think that uh
this next place we go with um Yang and
Mills and and Gage theories is is it a
wonderful example
of nerve or you know trying to say well
okay this isn't working but we're going
to do it anyway because maybe someday it
will work so you know yangan Mills knew
about symmetries presumably they knew
about nerder theorem uh so they whe that
is a wonderful question whether they
knew about it at the time later in life
when I heard these stories from Yang
later in his life um it was clear that
he had deep respect not only for
symmetry but for not's
accomplishments what the degree to which
that was in his head in
1954 don't have an authoritative Source
but what's amazing from our current
perspective is the Symmetry that they
looked for or tried to take advantage of
was treating the neutron and the proton
as has two different identical things
and it's true that for some purposes you
can do that but they're clearly not I
mean maybe you as a working physicist
can explain to our audience of of
non-working physicists why would you
ever treat the neutron and the proton as
more or less the same thing and and how
did it not work well you would treat it
treat them as the same thing for the
same reason that when you're studying
classical mechanics neonian mechanics
and you think about throwing a ball
through the air you neglect air
resistance that the first the first idea
that you can get of how things are going
to go is just say there's no atmosphere
yeah I'm just going to worry about
gravity no spin on the baseball seams
and things like that so it's an
approximation they are they are two
particles that have uh in fact the same
strong interactions we've learned
through experiments they have very
nearly the same mass you can sort of say
that if uh what's the difference between
the two the difference between the two
is that the the proton has a charge and
the neutron doesn't yeah now then you so
the first thing you'd say is well proton
is a charge the neutron doesn't so the
proton should have a little electromatic
magnetic energy and way more than the
neutron except that it doesn't it's the
other way around for reasons that have
to do with details and that we all know
about now but you wouldn't have if we
were making the world we probably
wouldn't have made it that way right
although it's good for us that we have
because it makes the proton staple um
so what's interesting about U the Yang
Mills theory is that although everybody
said it's not the theory of the nuclear
forces physicists especially those
practicing field theory in my childhood
were fascinated by it and there were
many people who tried to do something to
the theory that would make the force
particles massive so that the nuclei
could be in finite size rather rather
than as big as they want them to be lots
of good work was done there most people
didn't get the right
answer the right answer turned out
didn't have to do with nuclear forces at
all because without fooling around in
that way if you apply this this uh
strategy not to isospin but to the color
symmetry that we attribute to quarks the
more fundamental constituents uh you get
the theory of Quantum chromodynamics
which as we call it is a new law of
nature yeah tells us how protons come to
be and neutrons come to be and so on so
the way this was applied successfully a
little before Quantum chromodynamics was
with the Insight that this could form
the basis of a theory of the weak
interactions many steps along the way
the weak interactions was learned in
1957 by a couple of brilliant
experiments that we talk about um
distinguishes left-handed and
right-handed interactions the particles
concerned like the electron and the
nutrino uh have left-handed pieces and
right-handed pieces just like we do and
they're similar but not the same and
whereas in electromagnetism the
left-handed electron and the
right-handed electron have the same
charge so they behave the same way in
reality and under symmetries the
left-handed and right-handed electrons
don't
and so the Symmetry that you'd like to
make has to be hidden as we say and the
right analogy from that U came from the
phenomenon of super
conductivity superc conductivity
everyone knows has uh a great miraculous
property that there are these substances
that when cooled to very low
temperatures conduct electricity without
any resistance they don't heat up they
don't glow and anything you start at
curred it'll go forever a vast
technological importance even for the
magnets that we use to build our
accelerators today but superconductivity
has a second magical property which is
that magnetic field can't penetrate very
far into a
superconductor which means in the funny
way that physicists think that inside
the superconducting medium the normally
massless Photon acquires a mass well the
photon is still coming from a symmetry
principle but in this special substance
the special surroundings it becomes
massive and that is a u a model for how
the force carriers of the weak
interaction could acquire a mass that
you know in
some H I don't know some weird way we're
all living inside a metaphorical
superconductor exactly I mean and all
the better for it I do want to dwell on
this because I think it's an interesting
insight for the that's hard to convey to
people who don't do science for a living
Yang and Mills and their friends you
know so they knew they were in the
atmosphere whether they literally read
the paper or not there was this idea
that symmetries could lead to forces and
they were just trying to implement this
and there's an obvious problem the
neutron and proton didn't look very
symmetric one had a charge you know the
other one had a different Mass Etc but
they bulldo forward anyway and they
found more problems like oh there's
supposed to be massless particles we
don't see that either and and yet like
you just said it was so beautiful that
people said well we're going to keep
trying we're going to keep banging our
head at it and trying to make it work I
don't think I want to hear your
viewpoint on this but one could make the
same kind of or one could argue that's
analogous to what string theorists are
doing right now right you have a
beautiful structure it's looks very
different than the real world it's in 10
dimensional SpaceTime and there's 10 to
500 different vacuums States but the
people who are in favor of this Theory
say but it's just something like this
has got to be right let us keep working
on it and we'll find it
eventually so um I think there is an
analogy and it's one that I don't know
enough to describe very well but I'll
tell you a little bit more about the
Yang bills Theory I when I was a
Stonybrook Jim
Simons famous Quant mathematician was in
the department we're all in the same
building on the same floor and
he and yang decided that we should get
the mathemat mathematicians and the
theoretical physicists together great
idea uh and the first topic was going to
be Yang Mills
theories so there was an
evening um there might even have been
wine I don't remember and yang explained
his very physical Democratic motivation
for stumbling on Yang Mills
theories this was stunning to Jim
Simons who had invented the same
mathematical structures called fiber
bundles by pure reason without you know
saying it should be my choice and your
choice and protons and neutrons and all
that and the next the next week Jim
Simons gave his Discovery path pretty
unintelligible to me I have to say in
which Yang was stunned by the notion
that without reference to physical
reality you could come up with the same
concept um I suspect a lot of what's
going on in string theory and the
attempts to relate it either to problems
in particle physics or
information when understood we may find
that there's a similar Duality and that
uh you know various smart people who are
coming from One Direction or the other
May in fact meet someday and that would
be fun to fun to see right and and the
most fun is the fact that it's also
possible that it's all just wrong right
like Yang and Mills could have been
wrong you don't know ahead of time you
exact you have to do the work it's th
this is one of the seductive aspects of
the Met strategy you can apply it to any
old symmetry that you think you see in
the universe and for most of those it
does not lead to a viable Theory well it
leads to a mathematically viable Theory
but it doesn't lead to a theory of this
world right so you can still apply it in
the wrong way well and I I think that we
need to give some uh explication to
symmetry breaking because basically uh
you to to give away the game because we
both talked about this in in different
formats and I'm sure the audience has
heard about it there's two really
interesting ways in which the Yang Mill
strategy is implemented in the real
world but both are extremely subtle and
uh unintuitive one in the weak
interactions one in the strong
interactions and so for the weak
interactions all the complaints we've
been making about Yang and Mills are
basically right the two identical
particles are the electron and the
neutrino they look very different but
the Symmetry is broken and that makes it
all
work it's true what would you like me to
say well I guess the the journey to get
there because my impression is that when
brow and angir and higs and everyone was
was thinking about breaking symmetry or
even I guess when nambo and Goldstone
were thinking about spontaneous symmetry
breaking at the very beginning they were
mostly thinking about the strong
interactions not the weak
interactions yes for um it so there was
there are six people who basically did
the uh had the Insight of how you could
hide the Symmetry how hide a symmetry in
a gauge Theory um it's quite complicated
the way people proceeded because you
know like us uh modern feeble people
they didn't know where they were going
at the time they're doing what they
could even though they were very clever
people um so it was sort of a question
could you have a theory that had these
wonderful properties of gauge symmetry
which gives you constraints it makes
this coupling relate to that coupling
and so on uh it gives you a theory
that's well behaved up to the sky in
very high energies so very
desirable um but in which the this
symmetry in which you do things that you
couldn't within the Symmetry and the
thing that you couldn't do within the
Symmetry say is to give a mass to the
electron and as we we mentioned earlier
that's because the left-handed and
right-handed electrons that you have to
put together to have a mass behave
differently under the symmetry so people
were challenged by that problem uh Peter
higs was responding to a guess by a
couple of physicists of pen benley and
Abe kleene who thought they had a way of
doing that and they were attacked by
Walter Gilbert later a Nobel Prize
winner in Biochemistry who said don't
you guys know
anything and as Ben described it to me
we were completely defenses defenseless
and Peter hicks's attention was
attracted by that particular episode the
other guys came came to it at about the
same time uh remarkable coincidence in
time through slightly different stimuli
and higs realized that there was
something special about a gauge theory
that the common prejudices didn't
operate and wrote his very clear paper
including one in which he uh enunciated
perhaps more clearly than other people
had the uh the necessity of a new
particle which we now call the higs
boson slightly unfairly to all the rest
of them um and um showed how you could
hide a symmetry and have your cake and
eat it too yeah none of the those six
people and I guess I've met and talked
with all of them who even in old age
were quite clever some of them are still
with us thought of applying this insight
to the problem of the weak
interactions then came some other people
including our friend uh Gard at one of
the the makers of these uh these
theories who were trying still to rescue
Yang and Mills
Yeah by finding a mechanism that would
give Mass to the force particles of the
nuclear force so that that was actually
his path into this problem this goes
back to your your first question about
the funny way we organize the material
it because you get your stimulation from
places that don't may not make any sense
when you're giving The Logical um
development of the subject uh so that
was his his path in and then the first
person person who comined things all the
all the pieces in the way that almost
gave us the full theory of the week in
electromagnetic interactions was Steven
Weinberg right building on some
symmetries that had been emphasized by
Shelley
glashow uh mentioned first by shelle's
advisor Julian
schwinger and um you know then required
further development to turn into the
theory that we know now but that was the
idea that you could put these these two
ideas together well really came from
from Weinberg you know in my upcoming
book there's only I again something I
feel bad about there's only one plot
with data in it and the plot with data
in it is the number of citations per
year to weinberg's paper yes because no
one paid any attention to it when it
first came out in 1967 the paper that
actually unified the electromagnetic and
weak interactions including as uh Sydney
Coleman pointed out in a famous article
in science Steve wein
he was off doing other things that
seemed much more promising at the time I
mean do you want to give the listeners a
little bit of a physical insight into
how what we now call the higs mechanism
breaks these symmetries that are so
important
ha uh you probably have been searching
as I have for years for a 25-word
explanation that's why love floing into
you you got me yeah it it is hard but it
but I guess the the punchline is it it
it sort of reminds us that Yang and
Mills when they treated the neutron and
the proton as maybe symmetric weren't
that wrong like there's a way that they
could have been symmetric it didn't
quite work for them but but that's right
and you could apply this to their Theory
it wouldn't be the theory of our world
but it would be a perfectly respectable
theory in which there there are some
massive Force par particles and then no
it is it is subtle and uh you know the
second subtlety is that um if you're
asked exactly how the higs field gives
Mass to the
electron there are actually two aspects
of that one is how does it happen and
that we sort of understand although I
think we do need a Blackboard still to
explain it y um and then the second is
how did it get the number that it is
about which we have no clue that is one
of the the open questions
uh one of the things that the
experiments at the large hyron collider
are showing us is that it is very very
plausible that the he higs field thing
that makes the higs boson is responsible
for the mass of the w and z bosons the
top and bottom and charm Cork and maybe
the
others but it's very frustrating because
within our Theory there is no
calculation you can do that will say
what the number should be it's not that
we're too lazy or
haven't developed the techniques there
just is nothing so it's coming from
somewhere else which means luckily
there's more to learn well this is
wildly out of chronological order but
when we turned on the Large Hadron
Collider and discovered the higs and we
were all very happy we we haven't
discovered anything else yet in terms of
new fundamental particles how surprising
is that to
you so I you carefully qualified your
negative statement say FAL particles you
can Define them as you as you have among
the new strongly interacting particles
by the like the pon and the proton and
the neutron I think they're up to 86 new
particles so things are happening you
know maybe not that we'll change our
view of the fundamental laws of nature
but will guide us in understanding how
those laws are implemented by nature
which is another problem I like to work
on because the problem of the higsbo on
Electro week symmetry breaking and so so
on if you work on that you're working on
a 30 or 40e time scale I think for me it
was 35 years between my first
Fascination and the discovery and still
continuing whereas for these other
problems which are more like engineering
problems or Applied Physics problems you
get to find out in six months or a year
whether you're full of it or you got the
right answer for something so that is
fun I think the thing that has surprised
me most
is uh there is this standard model of
the fundamental particles and
interactions the six porks the six
leptons the three interactions plus
gravity still off to the side
and to be slightly
uh lacking in
respect I know the people who made up
this Theory
and they're not actually Gods they're
pretty good there is this uh
absence it's a feature of the the theory
of the weak interactions is applied to
the strongly interacting particles the
quarks that the weak neutral current
interaction the thing carried by the
zosan doesn't change the flavor of the
corks or leptons
involved and so it doesn't change up to
strange or whatever that's right there's
a beautiful symmetry uh noticed by
Shelly glaso Johnny iliopoulos and
luchan mayani that guarantees that as
long as the corks and lepton is come in
pairs this is the way it's going to be
to First
approximation and I would have thought
because almost any generalization of the
standard model super symmetry
Technicolor something that doesn't have
a name yet breaks this and so I would
have thought we would have found
examples of violations of this really
approximate we thought symmetry but we
have it yeah so that either means that
the uh the standard model is yet more
brilliant than we we knew yeah or that
there's something hidden going on that
we'll discover someday so you know
that's not the discovery of a new
particle but it's it I that's a crack I
thought would be in our right our theory
that hasn't
cracked well yeah this like when we're
talking about historical incidents we
can say oh yes they were very brilliant
or they were very dumb but in the
present moment we're we don't know the
answer to a whole bunch of questions and
we know that 50 years from now people
will be saying that we're very clever or
very dumb depending on whether we guess
right uh and you know from time to time
we're both all of these people were very
clever but they might not might not have
had the fa yeah that's right and it's
it's our job and the job of people
younger than us both in the an
experiment to find the soft spots and to
make it better well let Let's uh rewind
a little bit now because the the weak
interactions with which take advantage
of the higs mechanism uh and you wegen
and Salam Etc uh helped us understand
very well the strong interactions with
the quarks are on the one hand a more
pure realization of Jen mills's idea but
on the other hand what a journey that
was like to realize that there were
these particles that you can never see
and there's three of them and they have
colors where did all that start where's
the first idea that maybe protons and
neutrons have other little particles
inside I think it came from desperation
from so a different kind of symmetry uh
classification symmetry or as we would
call it now a global symmetry uh during
the 1950s early 1960s people using
accelerators and bubble Chambers were
finding dozens of
particles and
uh there was a struggle to try to
classify them in a way that would make
them make sense some of them are strange
particles or doubly strange or triply
strange even and
um people notice people tried all sorts
of symmetri so there are many there's a
a junk heap of History where people
tried all sorts of symmetries that uh
you know when you had the first seven
particles looked pretty but then you
found an eighth particle and it didn't
fit uh you know it's not useless because
lots of those people got University
tenure by writing their wrong what we
now know to be wrong theories very
important so the
um as as is well known su3 symmetry the
flavor su3 symmetry was proposed by
maray Gilman and you've all name
on and then you ask yourself well okay
this the Symmetry applies but it turns
out that in contrast to isospin or other
symmetries that we know about we only
see families representations of the
Symmetry that correspond to the first
few smallest sets that would reflect the
symmetry so where does that come from so
two people George swag and M Gman
independantly imagin that if you took an
unseen member of the smallest family of
the three Symmetry and you combined one
of these and one of those or three of
these you could make the observed
particles and no more so pretty
brilliant yeah George was uh is he's
still with us uh was from the beginning
very mechanically minded he thought it
was compelling that these little things
were real the things that we now call
quarks Murray was more diffident about
it and uh the first first conference I
ever went to when I was about to begin
graduate school at Berkeley in
1966 as I was arriving in Berkeley there
was the International Conference in high
high energy physics what we now call IEP
and in those days any Street person
could pay $5 doll and go in and sit in
the back of the room and see those her
these Heroes of the Republic talking
holding forth about things so it's
fascinating to me partly because the
heroes of the Republic instead of
talking about Grand principles and
contemplating their Naval we're talking
about little phenomena that they wanted
to understand things that were bugging
them yeah one of the talks was given by
Murray gilban and he talked about quarks
but first he explained how the Quark
notion of these fundamental constituents
was not inconsistent to the reigning
Doctrine at Berkeley at the time the
bootstrap principle that all of the
particles protons pons chons things like
that were made of each
other uh promoted mainly by Jeff Chu and
whole this whole uh Cy of of quite
brilliant people who made fantastic um
calculational Innovations to do that and
to understand the strong interactions so
bur Murray was always diffident about
this and would say well maybe they're
just convenient mathematical
fictions um but George was a True
Believer from the beginning well both of
them turn out to be right uh maybe you
know maybe
was was more credulous and Murray was
more careful but Murray was someone who
gave the name of cork so he wins out in
the end his own own way I I don't know
if if you know but George Johnson who
wrote is a science writer who wrote a
biography of Gilman uh you know at first
Murray
was cooperating with the biography
writing process but of of course
eventually they had a falling out and
they became bitter enemies which
happened with Murray a lot apparently
but the issue over which the falling out
happened was George simply pointed out
that at first Murray kept saying the
quarks might be fictitious they might
just be a mathematical convenience and
gilmon wanted to say no I always thought
that they were real and you know you you
just read his paper though even though
according to George's testimony Murray
once said oh concrete qu quarks those
are for
Blockheads I believe it but but it we
have to remember those of us who are not
expert physicists that there was a
separate move you you invent quarks you
say okay there's up quarks down quarks
strange quarks uh the the particles that
we discovering in these wonderful
experiments are all made of them but
that was a separate move to say okay but
they come in three colors red green and
blue and you know how did who in the
world invented
that so that's a very complicated well
let me let me say one thing about the
quarks you know um consequences that
were perhaps not foreseen
the trouble with these the Quark
hypothesis was that nobody had ever seen
a quark yeah right that's a good one and
uh so there two aspects of that one were
people trying to prove that you should
have seen them or that you didn't see
them and then there were experimental
searches the most Innovative that I know
about was some characters who put
forward the notion that quarks were
concentrated in oyster
shells and so they acquired vast numbers
of oysters
disposed of the oysters in the uh most
ecologically favorable way and then
ground up the oyster shells to look for
quarks which they didn't find but they
did get to eat a lot of oysters you go I
don't don't know whether the Office of
Naval Research bankr that or or who was
the like you said they're all very
clever people here that we're talking
about that's right um so one of the
things that uh led to people taking cork
seriously was that in 1968 there were
experiments at the Stanford linear
accelerator Center done by people from
MIT and slack that seemed to indicate
that inside the
proton there were little charged
particles that actually behaved as if
they were sort of
independent these famous experiments in
which high energy electrons were
scattered from the protons and really
looked like they were bouncing off
little hard things they were
um and so the question is if they're
acting as if they're independent inside
the proton why don't they come out and
in my generation I guess I was either
lucky or unlucky to have not had this
disease it was great sport to show that
this was impossible within the context
of field Theory and so people did
calculations on Quantum electrod
Dynamics and theories of three or four
scalar particles and so on went on and
on
this the answer was always the same that
this idea that they could be independent
and still you know held together so they
they were inside a coherent Proton or
Neutron just couldn't happen in field
Theory well naturally people put off the
hardest calculation till
last the hardest calculation was the
generalization of Yang Mills Theory it's
not that hard but it takes two or three
pages to do um and miraculous ly in that
theory it turned out that you could have
both features that if you hit something
really hard it looked like it was
independent of the other things around
it and if you pulled on it and tried to
separate them it became harder and
harder to do so so you couldn't get them
out so that was a great Insight of
1973 by uh
um will Che and
pollitzer um in interestingly they were
were there were precursors of this in
the Russian literature for
example T had a a whiff of it maybe had
it um because we don't always Rec you
know even in our own work we don't
always recognize when we've done
something that means anything yeah until
after somebody else becomes famous
for well you were you were around and
involved in those days um give us a
little bit of a hint of what it felt
like to be doing particle physics that
magical time when it seemed like every
few months an experiment would pop up
and and turn the world upside down I
mean the idea that you could shoot
electrons at nucleons and say oh there's
little hard particles inside uh is is
pretty breathtaking it it was
breathtaking it was uh you know I look
back at I went to Berkeley for graduate
school because I didn't know exactly
what I wanted to do it was a big
department that had great people in many
different domains
my fantasy When I Was An undergraduate
was that I was going to grow up to be
like fairy and um do experiments and
make
calculations and that U you know that
would be fine well I got to work at a
laboratory name for a fa so close as I
came it's not so bad uh and then through
uh you know the random things that
happen when you go to graduate school I
had uh so I was interested in Berkeley
for two reasons one was that at the time
I had that I was applying I had a
girlfriend from Alam California who said
you must go west and then she dumped me
there you go but changed my life and the
other was I had read an account in the
New York Times about uh talk at the
Washington APS meeting about people who
had collided beams of electrons with
each other at Stanford
University and it was very primitive uh
later on I got to to meet the many of
the people who had done this and and
know them well the idea was that with
only a 100 million electron volts or so
you could make these head-on collisions
so it would be much more efficient than
an electron colliding with a stable
Target stationary Target and in fact the
uh to get to those energies at fmy lab
took another 30 years for people to
reach those energies of the
electrons um and I when they first did
the reported the experiment they said we
observe one Collision every 15 minutes
wow now we're getting tens of millions
per second at the large hyron collider
so technology has moved on so I was
really taken with that and then I I read
another article about that
Enterprise which said that they were
going to collide these electron beams
with each other and they didn't know
what would happen so I thought that was
fantastic yeah that you don't get to
look it up in the back of the book
it's not that they said we don't know
what we're doing it said we don't know
what happened so so I was driven to come
to the West Coast for that reason and
then at Berkeley the first people that I
meant that I wanted to be like were
doing particle physics it could have
gone another way uh but we should
mention that uh your book unlike uh this
podcast uh does a wonderful job of going
into the experiments absolutely giving
the experimenters a huge amount of
credit and you know just to drive at
home these days were're blaz about
building a particle accelerator uh
that's what we do a collider in
particular but the idea of colliding two
very skinny beams of ultra high energy
particles that's not an easy thing to
pull off from an engineering point of
view to make those make those beams
skinny is not uh not an easy trick at
all and you know both Bob and I are are
blessed not only to have grown up but
this period when particle physics was
changing so dramatically
um but also because of where we've
studied and and worked to be around
people who have made a lot of these
Miracles technological Miracles yeah so
uh one of the people who helped teach us
how to make these very strong brilliant
beams was Ernest
karant child of Richard karant of
Gigan who taught me mathematical physics
When I Was An undergraduate at Yale and
then later was a colleague when I was
helping to design find the super
collider that never happened and um so I
got to know just how clever these people
are you know they may be wired a little
differently from uh somebody grows up to
be an experimentor or a theorist in
straight particle physics but um I just
have enormous admiration for people who
know to know how to make things that
work
and that particular you know back in
those days what were the leading
experiments that that were being done
there was uh slack at Stanford was was
fmy lab up and going at that time no so
FY lab had its first beams in
1972 I actually went there in the for a
semester in the fall of 72 when there
was a lot of mud and and on a good
weekend there would be beams for a few
hours yeah uh some of the experiments
there were um using an internal Target a
gas jet Target inside the accelerator
others were with ex uh extracted beams
and the big news at that time was what
we started to call inclusive reactions
okay so this is something that was uh
pushed by Richard Fineman JD
borcan uh Ken Wilson and others Yang
also was a proponent of that and it
marked a transition from the time when
people
studying the interactions of protons and
Pion in bubble Chambers would look for
two or three or four particles being
produced in the final state to dozens
now we have thousands occasionally tens
of thousands and the heavy iron
collisions and we were beginning to
apply techniques of statistical physics
rather than looking for individual
residences to try to understand what the
strong interactions were really like uh
and I being on the spot there and and uh
and then when I went back to Stony Brook
I continued and then I came back to fmy
lab um we were able to do things that I
thought were very insightful about the
strong interactions and which stand up
even
today and I remember uh having just
moved to FY lab very proud of how the
progress we'd made it was much more than
I thought AR priori would be made and
then came the discovery of the JS
particle which was revolutionary and
recalibrated me about what was really
important physics and so I changed what
I was doing at that point well this is
great because that's exactly the other
thing I wanted to talk about
um I think that people get a little
misimpression when they read a little
bit of the history of particle physics
like the ji particle it was discovered
it's made of a charm quark and an anti-
charm quark and so what's the big deal
like okay you've already found three
quarks you found a fourth Quark you know
why why is that so exciting at the
time well it's very exciting at the time
because uh from that day unless you were
really
recalcitrant you had to be pretty
convinc convinced that quarks were real
mechanical objects so that may be the
moment at which Murray stopped claiming
they were fictional identities fictional
entities uh
and The Charmed cork was
necessary for this uh symmetry
discovered by glaso ilad alphus and
mayani that kept the neutral currents
from changing flavor there had to be
such a thing and then they had to come
in Paris after that so that ratified
ratified or validated that idea um
people had imagined the consequences of
this once there were neutral currence
and they behaved the the that was
discovered in 1973 at CERN and they
behaved as specified than the charm
Court seemed like it had to be there my
colleagues at fa lab in 19 so I I was
there in the fall of 72 7374 my
colleague benley invited me to come
there once a week once a month for a
week and during that time he and John
Rosner and Mary K guar writing a paper
called search for charm about why charm
had to be there what the properties
would be like and it was one of these
delicious circumstances in which they
Tom applequist and David pollitzer had
AAG what it would be like if there were
a residence of a charm and Edie charm
suddenly on that day if this turned out
to be true as it did we realized that
nature had taken our Collective ideas
more seriously than we have and that
happens a few times in a career really
wonderful right that's a wonderful
moment I mean you you got smacked down
enough but if you find that your your uh
the shortcoming in your work was to be
too timid about
and that nature took it seriously that's
fantastic right and I guess I did
mention uh We've mentioned slack and
fery lab but I I do want to say that
CERN had been around for quite a while
all the all this time yes so CERN I I
was lucky to go to CERN for the my first
year as a postto at stoning Brook
19771 uh everybody including C Yang was
very generous to me Yang sent me to a
meeting in dub in the Soviet Union that
he didn't want to go to and I got to
meet some of the Gods of of Russian
physics po corvo grieva fun and so on I
wish I'd spent more time with them um
and then I stopped at CERN on the way
back and so my association with CERN
goes back to that time when I was a kid
that nobody knew and had never done
anything but people treated me like a
grown-up and made me feel welcome from
the beginning uh just uh I mean they
didn't have to because it's such a busy
busy place um CERN was just making the
transition from a place that had been
created after the war so European
nations could do something together
peaceful cooperatively and for decades
it was the singular example of
successful European Co cooperation you
know now there are other things but
cernus has gotten even stronger in its
reputation and um it had been had
reputation for doing sort of ponderous
experiments uh up to a time and then
they really found their footing and they
built the first uh colliding beams
machine of protons on protons starting
in 1970 or so um so that was operating
when I first went there and then uh
toward the end of the 70s they uh got
the idea well they had the large bubble
chamber experiment that found the
neutral currents I was there that summer
in 1973 and got to
witness the uh deliberations within the
collaboration well from the
outside I I wasn't privy to the to all
of the the invective but you know people
were really asking themselves do we have
an effect or is it some back background
we have in being re really meticulous
because as Jack Steinberger said if
there had been neutral currents fairy
would have told me told me about them
and then the next summer he was giving
lectures on
neutr uh so you know these things were
going on CERN was really becoming a big
player on the international scene and
then built the uh uh super proton syron
proton Eddie proton collider that
discovered the w and z bosons and has
been uh if not the center of the
universe for us right at least one of
them from ever since and it's a a great
place I'll be there in a week again oh
good uh you know we haven't said so
explicitly but probably most listeners
at this point know that the elementary
particles come in the two kinds of
fermans and bans and maybe they don't
know that Bans are always discovered in
Europe and Fons are always discovered in
the United States so far well there
might be an exception to that okay and
that is
Photon which wasn't believed until the
Compton effect was observed in the
United States and you could make an
argument that the electron was
discovered in Cambridge England you know
these uh these rules are never uh quite
completely accurate symmetries always
have a little bit of breaking in them
but okay so I mean it's a it's just a
fantastic human story of the
construction of the standard model of
particle physics with all the fits and
starts and like you said and this is a
theme of the books that I'm writing
right now the equations are smarter than
we are and you know we are often taught
by nature to take them more seriously
than we do from from direct
onwards but or I maybe but is not the
word but
the standard model's been around for a
while now right it's been a huge success
story and has put us in this weird place
where our theories are better than we
are we're we don't
have super reliable anyway anomalies
that are pointing us to new physics so
you know with that the end of the
podcast we can speculate a little bit
what what do you think about the next 50
years of partical physics and
fundamental physics more generally well
about the last third of our book is
devoted to questions to which we don't
know the
answers uh it is true that nothing has
hit us in the face recently from the
Large Hadron Collider that we
fundamentally don't understand but we do
have little things like the dominance of
matter over Addy matter in our
universe which has baffled people since
at least the 1950s when they uh I mean
that's another story that for people
under 90 years old I think is difficult
to understand why after the positron was
discovered did people think there was
any doubt that there would be an Eddie
proton they did and their reasons
weren't actually stupid uh you just have
to put yourself in their their frame of
mind um and all sorts of what we now
think of as screw ball ideas have been
invented to to explain why we only see
matter around us but that's that's a
real puzzle and you know speaks to our
our existence so how can you not be
interested in that um there's the rest
of the matter in the universe the dark
matter which we you know some people
thought I I think I might have mentioned
this possibility but I didn't Advocate
it thought would be discovered in the
first eight minutes of running at the
large col Dark Matter there was a chance
it's uh could have happened and then
there's the uh the phenomenon of uh Dark
Energy The Accelerated expansion of the
universe which is uh I followed when it
was happening because I was a member of
a Review Committee at lbl and so I was
hearing the updates on this and from the
beginning
and I would say that the experiment the
observations of you know the idea that
you would measure the expansion of the
universe for which there is new news
this week from the trip ASAS meeting um
was from the beginning going to be a
test of The Observers rather than of
nature
because our Cosmo cosmologist friends
and you masquerade is one of them from
time to time the inflationist as we call
them
uh argued that the Universe was exactly
at the critical
density and so there was going to be
Dark Matter to make
that and under those circumstances since
you never bet against Einstein there's
this deceleration parameter that people
were going to measure and it was going
to be two or minus two depending on your
conventions and if you so that was going
to be the answer and you'd Pat the guys
on the head after they got the answer
and said your Technique worked very good
except that's not the answer uh so
there's a place where we were hit in the
face by what some people might with
reason have thought was going to be the
most boring investigation you could do
right you're just GNA check the doxs and
say oh yeah Einstein guy he's right
again well of course it was Einstein
plus all the other people who weren't
right again and are some of our good
friends um so there are these surprises
that have come up um and the beautiful
thing about the development of modern
physics is that what we learn about the
fundamental theories of the forces and
what we see out in the sky are related
uh there is gravity which itself is a
theory that comes from amurter symmetry
principles although that's not how
Einstein got there um so there's a a
great coherence among these things and I
think for all of us who are grown-ups
and for our students the notion that we
try to pay attention to as wide a
spectrum of these things as we can and
understand how in the same way that
we've tried to indicate how a
technological development might inform
the way we do it experiments and
therefore what we think about in
theory just trying to pay attention to
the whole range of what's going on makes
us better at what we our little corner
of the world but there are May I don't
know whether it's it's I don't want to
emphasize it too much there are also
little hints from particle physics of
things that don't quite fit and and
those tend to go away but since I have
you here I mean are you optimistic about
work on these you know little slightly
annoying discrepancies that pop up from
time to time I am yes uh so I would
probably bet against every individual
one but hope that a few of them will
purs ass um one that is um particularly
apt now at fmy lab is the measurement of
the Magnetic Moment of the muon which is
something so there's the electron the
muon and similar particles have magnetic
moments the Magnetic Moment of the
electron is something that following dur
we should be able to calculate with no
excuses it's been measured to a fraction
of a part per trillion and at that level
essentially agrees with experiments all
they're all these digits um in which
Theory and experiment agree there is a
little bit
of puzzlement confusion there because
you have to put in one number other than
the electron Mass to make the
calculation and that is the strength of
the the uh electromagnetic interaction
the fine structure constant and that's
been measured just St stupendous
precision in two places in Berkeley and
Paris by people who are geniuses of
making these measurements and they don't
quite agree in the 12th or 13th digit
and when you P PL plug that into the
calculation of the Magnetic Moment of
course you get two different answers and
the measurement at the moment six
exactly between those two which is just
the way a theorist would have them but
that could be a sign of something that
we don't understand but for the muan
there is a much because muan is a more
massive particle there is a much greater
opportunity for physics other than
Quantum electrodynamics to intervene and
influence the answer and we now have a
situation in which uh experiments first
at Brookhaven well even before that at
CERN then at brookh Haven and now at fmy
lab are giving very beautiful very
precise answers that don't quite quite
line up with the best calculations we
have we know the soft spots or some soft
spots of those calculations and people
are working assiduously to make them not
quite so soft
there may be something great there to
find out it could be new interaction new
kind of particles or just that theorists
are a little behind the experimenters
and making our calculations as precise
as uh they could be so that's work being
done by by many really serious people
and we'll see what happens the
experiment has uh a bit more data than
they already have that they'll report on
in another year and a half or so in the
absence of a surprise there we'll just
tighten the limits on their number and
then theorists have to put up but as
we've seen from uh the whole discussion
we've had we don't know ahead of time
what are the places from which the
surprises are going to pop up right
right so I'm looking forward to whatever
surprises we get next and with that
Chris quig thanks so much for being in
the mindscape podcast okay thanks a lot
pleasure for me do mention the name of
the book I will absolutely do that
everyone should go out and read it
thanks okay thanks a lot goodbye
[Music]
than